All right. Well, let's uh
let's get uh get started here. I did see
a couple people uh walk in at uh kind of
last minute. Um if you haven't already
uh read the slide there, uh you'll
notice the slide has the uh first bit of
instructions. Uh send an email. That
email address that you see right up
there, so peckjohn+aiworld@github.com,
and then just as the subject, just put
in your GitHub handle. One quick note
about the GitHub handle, if you are
using enterprise managed users, uh this
is going to need to be a personal um
GitHub handle. So, that email address,
and then
your GitHub handle as the uh as the
subject. Again, not
but
you know what to do. So, go ahead and uh
and do that. And uh while everybody's uh
getting settled, then uh let's go ahead
and get rockin' and rollin'. So, uh my
name is Christopher Harrison. Uh the
gentleman over there is uh John Peck.
And uh we are both uh enterprise
advocates at uh GitHub, uh obviously
doing a whole lot of uh developer
relations stuff. So, basically talking
to customers and uh doing events like
this, primarily focused in on developer
experience in this little thing called
GitHub Copilot. So, this is going to,
hopefully, be a hands-on lab. Now, I am
going to put out a couple of real quick
caveats, because we had the exact same
lab this morning, and we ran into a
couple of challenges, the biggest of
which with the Wi-Fi network. That
because of what we're going to be doing
is going to rely quite heavily on the
network, we're going to try. Okay? I'm
going to repeat that one more time. We
are going to try. We're going to give it
our best effort.
If it works, wonderful. And if it
doesn't work, here's what we're going to
do instead. Is you will still have a day
or two to be able to complete the lab,
and you can go ahead and complete that
on your own time. And what I will do
instead is I will start doing some
demos. I will um answer a whole bunch of
questions. Um the morning group had a
whole bunch of questions, and something
tells me that this group will also have
a whole bunch of questions. Been doing
enough Copilot talks, there always seems
to be an awful lot of questions. More
than happy to talk through all of that.
So, we are going to try our absolute
best. Hopefully, everything will work.
And if it doesn't work, we've got a nice
little fallback. And I want to make sure
again that I highlight, you will have
access to the lab um for a couple of
days after this event, so that way you
could go out and do it on uh on your own
time from uh from there. So, one last
time because I did see a couple of
people that just walked in,
notice instructions on the slide, please
send an email,
peckjohn+aiworld@github.com.
The subject, just put in your GitHub
handle again. Make sure that's your
personal or a non-enterprise managed
user account. If you don't know what
enterprise managed users are, don't
worry about it cuz then you probably
don't have one. If you have one,
you'll know it.
See a couple of knowing nods there.
Okay. Without any further delay, let's
go ahead and talk a little bit about
GitHub Copilot. So, John's going to be
working in the background here. Once um
um he is done working, I'm then going to
go ahead and uh make an introduction and
get everybody pointed at the uh at the
lab. But I want to get started by
talking about something that's very,
very important when we're working with
GitHub Copilot, and that is context.
That you'll notice that we have a
tagline for GitHub Copilot called your
AI pair programmer. Now, not only is it
wonderful marketing, it kind of is, um
but it's also a fantastic description of
how best to think about GitHub Copilot.
That you want to think about it as an AI
pair programmer.
And the example that I always give, the
analogy that I always give, is my
partner and I woke up the other day, and
she says to me, "Hey, I want to go to
brunch." Fantastic. Who doesn't love
brunch? And so, I recommended a spot,
and she looks at me and says, "You know,
here's the thing.
Been there an awful lot lately. I want
to go somewhere new."
Okay, fantastic. And then I recommended
another spot.
And then she says, "You know, now that
I'm thinking about it, I'm really kind
of craving waffles." Spectacular. Who
doesn't love waffles? And then I
recommended another spot. Now, that's a
very normal back and forth.
That what happened was is a request was
made, I had some level of context, and I
gave back a perfectly valid response.
And then some more context was provided,
and then I gave yet another response.
And that's a very common back and forth.
And that may have been context that she
had at the very beginning, and maybe
just hadn't yet shared. And it might
also have been context that she sort of
discovered as we were talking. Again,
all of this is very, very normal, and
it's how we think about when we're
talking about with other people, when
we're talking with human pair
programmers, and then also in turn with
that AI pair programmer. That context is
key.
Now, when we're talking about context, a
lot of times, we really focus in on the
prompt when we're talking about context
and AI.
That I see an awful lot, especially with
new developers to uh to Copilot, is
they're really worried about like,
"Okay, well, how do I craft a prompt?"
And don't get me wrong, prompt crafting
is an important skill.
But context goes beyond prompt crafting.
Because unlike a lot of other tools,
which are maybe going to run all of your
code through different parsers, or maybe
even build your code, or potentially
even like run your code,
Copilot, again, behaves like an AI pair
programmer. It's going to be reading
your code.
Just as if I brought somebody else new
on to the team, and they're going to
start reading your code. So, making sure
that that code is readable
becomes very important. So, if you have
good function names, good variable
names,
if your code is well structured,
Copilot's going to be able to navigate
that pretty well.
And if you're using a lot of
single-letter variables,
if you're using a lot of abbreviations,
Copilot's going to come along and it's
going to struggle with that, just again,
as another pair programmer would.
In addition,
comments. Now, we all know the point the
importance of commenting code. And there
is a strong part of me that has this
feeling that good code doesn't need
comments.
But here's the thing,
is having a line or two of comments
does help you make your code that much
more readable.
And so, even if it might be superfluous,
if it's going to make life easier, maybe
just go ahead and add that in, cuz it's
not going to, say, slow down your
application. So, having comments
describing what it is that you're going
to be doing, how it is that you're going
to be doing it, is really going to help
things out.
And then finally, last but not least, is
your project structure.
That having a good, navigable project
structure
is also going to help Copilot. Now, the
real takeaway that I want you to get out
of all of this is this is sort of like
just good code 101.
That having good code is really going to
help out an awful lot with context. I'm
going to come back to to questions a
little bit later.
Okay.
So, how do we then help Copilot help us?
And so, number one, context, we talked
about that. Number two, the intent. Make
sure that you're clear about the intent.
What is it that you are trying to do?
And be clear about that intent.
That one of the things that I see an
awful lot of developers do, especially
if they've maybe worked with like older
chatbots,
is when they start sending those initial
prompts,
that they're very terse.
Because they're used to dealing with
older chatbots that maybe weren't really
good at processing uh natural language.
And so, it basically became like using
command lines.
That's not what this is built for. So,
be clear. If you want something to be
done a particular way, and kind of
getting into the specificity aspect
here, tell Copilot. Or as I like to say,
don't be passive-aggressive
with Copilot.
That sometimes I'll see a new developer,
they'll go in, they'll they'll they'll
give like a very short prompt, and then
they'll go, "Well, wait a minute. Why
didn't Copilot figure this part out?"
Well, did you know that part? Well,
yeah. Did you tell Copilot? Well, no.
Okay, well, tell Copilot. Like if
there's an important piece of
information that you need Copilot to
consider, go ahead and make sure that
you tell Copilot that.
Okay.
Copilot supports a handful of different
workloads. Um you'll notice the one on
the far end, Copilot coding agent. I'll
get to that one in a minute. It's all
bright and sparkly and so forth. Um
that's not because that one's um
necessarily best. Um it's just because
it's the newest, and as we all know, we
need to just highlight and sparkle the
um the the the newest item.
So,
um first up, let's talk about code
completions. So, code completion is sort
of the original version, if you will, of
GitHub Copilot. This is where I'm going
in, I'm writing code, and then Copilot
will suggest the next line, it will
suggest the next function, and it will
suggest the next class. This is
wonderful. If you're in the zone, you
know what you're doing, you're typing
away, fantastic. And Copilot will be
able to support you right there.
Next up is chat. And originally, this
was single shot. That I go in, I ask a
question, and I get a response back. So,
maybe it can generate a single file for
me.
But the problem with that, as we think
about even the simplest of updates, like
if I go to update a web page, I'm going
to be updating an HTML, JavaScript, and
CSS file.
That's multiple files.
And so, this is where edits comes into
play. And with edits, Copilot is now
able to edit across multiple files.
And then we take that to the next level
with agent mode.
And with agent mode, now again, still
inside my IDE,
what Copilot's going to be able to do is
navigate your project,
figure out what needs to be done, and
then start building code. And it's able
to work iteratively, and it's able to
run external tasks, like for example,
running your unit tests. And if it
detects, "Hey, there's an error." it's
even able to self-heal. I'm going to
sneeze.
Thank you.
Okay. I I was waiting for the second
one. I usually sneeze in twos. It'll
It'll It'll show up in a minute here.
Um okay.
Um and then finally we get into coding
agent.
And coding agent is different because
this is going to be done inside of
github.com.
So, I'll have an issue on github.com,
and I can then assign that to coding
agent.
And coding agent will then work in the
background.
Figure out what needs to be done.
Be able to again run scripts. Be able to
self-heal. And then eventually create a
a pull request that you can then review,
and eventually merge into your code
base.
And so this is what we're going to be
exploring. Not going to worry too much
about these two slides here. There we
go. This is what we're going to be
exploring in this lab. John, how are we
doing?
We are doing splendid. I have two people
left to actually join.
I will need about 3 minutes to add them
all to Copilot.
Okay. But we can at least go in and
start accepting invitations.
You can go in and start accepting
invitations. One quick note, my Pope, I
don't believe I have your correct
handle. So, if you could send me a new
one, that would be great. Okay. And
there was one person who walked in just
a minute ago, so we'll need to get that
sorted as well, but we can get there in
a minute. Okay. So,
um first part to the lab.
Navigate to the URL that you see right
there. So, github.com  octo h o l
hands-on on lab. So, o c t o h o l.
Hotel Oscar Lima.
And then at the very top, and by the
way, I'm assuming that you're logged
into GitHub with the handle that you
sent over.
And then up towards the very top, you
should see accept invitation.
And then go ahead and select accept
invitation.
Now, here's the most important part
about today.
Silence means, "Hey, everything is
fantastic."
So, if you're not seeing it, please let
me know.
Um
Okay.
And then accept invitation right at the
very top. Okay.
Yep.
Did you send the email?
Okay.
All right.
Um I'll come back in a second.
Um
Hey John.
Do they need to ask for the Copilot
seat?
Need to explicitly ask. I am just going
through the process right now of adding
those in. Okay. Perfect.
It doesn't matter. Yeah, he's he's going
to be adding you in. Okay. Now, for
anybody who did not send the email
address,
um
please go ahead and send an email
to that address.
And then with your GitHub handle, I'm
going to leave that up for about another
15 seconds here because I'm trying to
keep things moving
for everybody as quick as I best can
here.
Um the I can share the share the slide
deck. Um my handle is geek trainer, and
you can basically find me on everywhere
with with that, including GitHub.
Geek trainer. g e e k
trainer.
Um uh GitHub. At GitHub.
Okay.
Now then,
let me
get
everybody rolling here.
So,
after you've accepted the invitation, um
who has not yet accepted the invitation?
Okay. And then what happened when you
went to octo hol? And by the way, I I I
want to make sure that I highlight
something. You'll You'll notice that
more people raised hands. Silence means
everything is fantastic. So, if
something is not working, please let me
know. Now, for people who um everything
is working fantastic, then here's what
you can do is go to that URL.
Actually going to modify the slide real
quick.
Is
And if we could get phones to a silent
or a vibrate, that would be wonderful.
Okay.
All right.
So,
um
to get started with the lab,
what you're going to do, navigate to
that URL that you see right there. So,
gh.io  agent-sdlc-lab.
When you get to the part to create your
repository,
the owner is going to be octo hol,
and then the name is going to be your
handle. Again, replacing your
See where that's going. And go ahead and
start working on exercises zero
and exercises one.
And I will let you have at it, and then
I'm going to start going around and
helping people get unstuck.
Okay.
Um
Hey John.
When uh when you have a minute?
Okay.
Uh right over here.
Did you send the email? Yes. Okay. Um
we'll go ahead and get John over to help
you out in a minute.
Yes.
Okay.
Did um was it maybe there earlier?
Do me a favor. Um hit plus right at the
top here.
Yeah, I'm hit new repository.
Just let's just test something real
quick.
Um hit the um drop down right here.
Um okay. We'll go ahead and get John
over here in just a minute. Sorry. Yeah.
Okay.
All right.
Now then,
remember, silence means everything is
hey
everything is fantastic. So, if
something is not working, please raise
your hand, otherwise we are never going
to know.
Oh, okay. So, note the owner. So, owner
is going to be octo hol.
Nope.
So, notice the slide. Okay, sorry.
And then the repository name is going to
be your handle. There you go. Yep. Hey.
Um okay. Then hold on for just a minute.
John will be over.
Hi.
Oh, okay. So, here's what we need to do.
Um
Yep.
No. Um so, yep. Uh perfect. So, go ahead
and hit enter.
And so go ahead and scroll down. And you
see the step zero here, set up the
environment. Let's go ahead and just hit
that.
And then now we're going to follow the
instructions from here. So, you'll
notice that you're going to want to open
up the
um that URL in a new tab, and then
you're going to select uh use a
template, and then create from there.
You're welcome.
All right.
How's everybody doing?
I know there's a couple of people that
John's going around to. Yeah.
Yes.
Yep.
Beautiful.
Doesn't matter.
Living on the edge.
Yeah.
Nope. I Um here's what you're going to
do is um
so, uh go to Okay. So, go to um docs.
And then just scroll on down, and um go
to step zero.
And then now go ahead and follow right
along with what this says here.
Yeah.
Oh, okay. So, nope. So, um we um we need
to go to the first part here. So,
navigate to that URL here.
So, go to
Yep. So, um real quick, as people are
getting started, I want everybody to
kind of notice the the steps on the
slide here. So, step one is go here.
What you're going to find there is a set
of instructions for the hands-on lab.
And then, in step zero, it's going to
have you then create your repository.
When you get to that step, you're going
to set the owner to octo-hol, and then
the name to your your handle. So, start
here, start working through the lab, and
then you're going to go in and um
uh and set that up.
Okay. So, let's go into step zero.
Yep. And then, now you'll notice it's
going to have you um open that up in a
new tab. It's going to have you create
from Exactly. Yep. And then, you're all
set.
Don't sit down yet.
Yes, just start at zero.
Okay. So, here's what we need to do is
um
um let's go ahead and um let's just um
to
um nope.
Um you see the uh the URL up at the very
top there, the gh.io? Okay. Um nope. It
looked like we um
uh didn't
uh it should be sdlc. So, let's go ahead
and just try that again. So, type in
Type nope. Nope. Stop. Yep. There we go.
So, gh.io
um slash agent
dash
sdlc.
Nope. Nope. Here, you have an sl. You
want sdlc? Yep. Dash lab.
Enter.
There we go. And so, now go ahead and
scroll on down.
And then, you'll notice there's step
zero. Let's go ahead and go right into
step zero.
And then now, it's going to have you
create your repository. So, if we read
through, we'll notice step one, we'll
open that URL up in a brand new tab, and
then follow the instructions from there.
Okay. So, um
Yep.
Nope.
Create a new repository.
Yep.
Nope. Put it into right at where it says
up on the slide. Hit the drop-down.
octo-hol
And then, the repository name will be
your handle.
Uh you can leave it as private. That's
fine.
Okay.
All right. You're welcome.
Yeah.
Mm.
Yeah, you can just go ahead and delete
that one. And then, okay. So, all you
have to do is go to settings.
Scroll all the way down. All the way.
Yep, there we go. And then, um hit that.
And then, you're going to hit delete.
And you're going to um you can actually
just copy and paste it.
Um and then, uh yeah.
Welcome.
Yo.
Correct.
Yeah, we can leave that unmerged. Yep.
Yeah. Yeah. We're just going in and and
kind of exploring it. There's also um
Yeah, I'll get to that in a minute. Ask
me that question again in in 5 minutes.
I don't want to interrupt everybody, but
it's there's an important thing there.
So, ask me that question again in 5
minutes.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah. You need to be signed in.
There you go.
Yeah.
Perfect.
Correct.
Yep. Yeah. And and just kind of keep on
following on with the uh with the lab
from there. What this is going to have
you do in a minute here is it's going to
have you open up um the your repository
again, and then you're going to create a
couple of issues and start playing
around with coding agent.
Yep.
Yep. Yeah. Well, that's uh the the lab
actually says to send a a hello
um to like um
um kind of wake it up.
Yeah. We we we had played with that.
I know.
Keep going.
Yeah.
Fantastic.
Oh, hey John.
He's having a premium requests error.
Oh, thank you.
I type really really fast. I don't type
I type accurately, but I type really
really fast.
See See, here's the thing about being a
developer. You don't have to spell
correctly. You just have to spell
consistently.
Yeah.
Yes.
Yeah, actually, if you're you know, if
you're like in a in a zone, and you
already like finish out step one and
want to start getting into step two, you
can go ahead and do that. You'll also
notice that all of the steps actually
include like little optional exercises.
So, if you are um you know, uh somebody
who kind of like just moves really
really fast, um there's other stuff to
do in in in that lab. So, yeah. So, go
ahead and um kind of keep working
through exercise one. Um I'm going to do
a an overview of exercise one in like
just a couple of minutes here.
For code spaces, no. So, code spaces is
a separate product. The reason that
we're using code spaces is it's
effectively a container in the cloud,
and so it just eliminates setup. So,
like it's wonderful for just development
in general, but especially something
like this, having people install
software, forget it. So, yeah.
Christopher.
That's okay.
So, Copilot uh for enterprise, which is
going to be like everything that we're
using, is $39.99 um a month. So, $40 a
month. Yeah. Um
uh there's also a business tier, which
does not um it There's a few different
features that it does include, um but
one of the biggest is going to be um
access to uh to coding agent. Um and
that's at $20 a month, or again, $19.99,
or whatever.
Uh yeah. Yep.
Yeah. Yep. Yeah. Yeah.
Um hit refresh real quick.
Yeah.
you still have
there we go.
All right, so
here's what I'm going to do. I know that
people are still working periodically.
I'm just going to come up here. I'm
going to kind of talk and highlight a
little bit about a feature. So this is
basically
a real quick overview of what it is that
you're doing in exercise one. You can
have a seat and get yourself
comfortable.
Pretend like you're an adult.
Do I look like an adult? No.
Proof that you work with somebody for
way too long.
Um
No, so
so let's talk a little bit about get a
co-pilot coding agent. So the whole goal
coding agent is to have a
an AI peer programmer that what I can do
is I can assign it a co-pilot issue or
sorry a GitHub issue and let co-pilot
begin work on it. Now the first big
thing about assigning an issue to
co-pilot. Remember that a whole speech
we did about context waffles all that
good stuff. Yeah, yeah, yeah. So context
context is key and so if we take a look
at the issue that we created
we went ahead and gave it a pretty
decent amount of detail about what it
was that we wanted to have accomplished.
So you'll notice that we're going to be
creating a functionality to allow for
submission of games. So here's all of
our requirements and kind of list them
all out and if this was going to be
something more robust. I might have even
dropped a potential workflow that I
wanted it to kind of step through as it
was building out all of the project.
Again, don't be passive aggressive with
co-pilot that if there's some piece of
information you wanted to see and
understand absolutely 100% tell it about
it.
Now the next thing is after you assign
it it needs an environment in which to
work.
And there is an there's a workflow
that you can create
and it's called he said speaking slowly
to stall co-pilot setup steps.
And so when co-pilot goes to do its work
it's going to be running inside of
GitHub actions
and it's going to step zero
run everything that it sees inside this
workflow. And if you look through this
workflow what you're going to notice is
a whole bunch of steps to install
different services and packages and so
forth. And that's now going to be the
environment in which it's able to do its
thing.
Now that also leads me to another very
big point which is about security.
Because here's what I'm going to do
is I'm going to take an AI agent
I'm going to assign it a task
and it's now able to go off and start
doing things.
And I want to make sure that everything
it's going to be doing is going to be
completely contained.
So the first big thing
about working with coding agent
is that it does not have access to
the internet.
That by default it is a firewall that's
going to block it from any external
resource.
Now you do have an ability
to open up the firewall if you do want
it to be able to access external
resources but by default it won't and
that includes by the way installing
frameworks and libraries.
So the only way it's going to have
access to frameworks and libraries is
either A you open up holes in the
firewall or B
you set this up to install all the
necessary libraries.
Number two
this is running inside
GitHub actions and if you're not already
familiar with GitHub actions one great
thing about it is that it's going to
launch an ephemeral space. So it's going
to set up a space it's going to do its
work inside of there and then it's going
to collapse down from there.
So it will not have access to any other
resources besides what's inside of
there. Number three
it does not have right access to your
repository save for the branch that it
creates.
So it cannot modify anything inside your
code base the only thing it's able to
modify is just its branch.
Number four
that branch you're going to notice will
not actually create a full pull request.
It's going to leave that in draft form
not become an actual pull request unless
you come along and say yes, I approve
this. Number five along those lines if
you are a good developer shop and you
have different requirements things like
security checks things like unit tests
end to end tests regression tests all of
which need to pass what you're also
going to notice is that on this pull
request none of that can actually run
Where's that button? Right there. Until
you click that button that says approve
workflow runs. So again trying to keep
it completely self-contained. And then
finally last but not least and this is a
question that was asked earlier about
reviewing it and then merging it in.
When it comes to the current version of
coding agent there is a restriction and
this is by design.
Um remember again coding agent is brand
new so this can always change but this
is by design that if you assign an issue
to coding agent you are not allowed to
then review its work. So you need
somebody else to review its work. So
basically it's sort of like in most
organizations you're not allowed to
review your own work you need to bring
somebody else in sort of the same thing
is that I assign the peer programmer and
then I need somebody else to come along
and say yes that this actually that this
actually is okay.
All right.
So questions on co-pilot coding agent.
That is a fantastic question.
And I'm just going to say that that is a
fantastic question.
And and and I'm going to say that's a
Um other questions?
That's a great question. So the question
is that was also a great question. So
the question is can you iterate? The
answer is yes is
what I can do let me zoom out a little
bit that was a little bit obnoxious
is I can just go in and add a comment.
So if I go in and I add a comment and I
say hey
um
what what I potentially want it to do
also add in an endpoint to search for
games by name. There we go.
Thank you.
And if I scroll back up give it just a
second here
and then we'll notice the cute little
eyeballs again.
So now what's happening is that co-pilot
has started work again and if I hit view
session
hopefully I've stalled just long enough
here
you'll notice that it's actually started
up a brand new session. So it's going to
take the work that it did and then it's
going to start back up again and begin
work again from there.
Yeah. Does it work with self-hosted
runners?
No.
Not at the moment. When? I
I shouldn't have even said at the
moment.
Let's let's let's summarize that answer
no.
Yeah.
I always feel like a press secretary
whenever I'm doing this.
So um
give me a little bit more about what
you're asking there. Yeah, so I have a
GitHub application.
Clients install my GitHub application.
It generates some rich prompts that we
want to use with basically GitHub
co-pilot to run something on their code
base. Can we do that? No. Okay. So what
you could do is you could stand up an
MCP server so that way they could use
co-pilot talk to your code and then
start to interact that way but you're
not going to be able to have co-pilot
like do something to somebody else's
code base. Okay, so it's not like an
open API that you can just have a
co-pilot stick in a code base to do
stuff. No. Yeah. Yeah.
So yeah, so what you can do is if you
have a pull request you can assign that
to to co-pilot at that point but again
it needs to be on a repository that you
own.
I don't know the answer to that. I'm I'm
going to be honest. I I don't know the
answer to because I don't know
necessarily like what an app is able to
do on
on behalf of the user at that point.
Um
I yeah, I would I
I I I would need to get back to you on
that. Yeah. My my handle is geek
trainer. Yeah, let me just
um
Here we go.
So, just shoot me an email and I can try
and dig up a
a more robust answer for you. Other
questions? Yeah.
Mhm.
Yeah.
Yeah, this is a this is a great question
and I'm actually going to up-level this
um a little bit. So, when we're talking
specifically about coding agent, if it
doesn't do um something that that uh
that I wanted it to or if it does get
something completely wrong. And keep in
mind that AI, just like human
developers, is going to periodically get
things wrong and it's sometimes going to
get things spectacularly wrong. Again,
just like humans are going to sometimes
get things spectacularly wrong. So, um
if that's the case, there's a few
different approaches that I could take.
So, one of them would be is just like I
did um here a minute uh
ago is or 3 minutes 57 seconds ago, but
who's counting? Um is just add in a
comment and just clarify, "Hey, this is
really what I wanted to use." So, that's
one option. Um if it's like completely
wrong, if it's just um completely out of
left field, then the next option is you
can just go back um all the way up to
the very top here um and under assignees
um and I'm not going to remove this cuz
I I want to let it keep doing its thing,
but just unassign Copilot,
change your issue, and then reassign
Copilot.
And then and then that way it will just
completely start from from scratch.
Um number three,
and I think this is always um
very important when when we're working
with AI is if we see it get something
wrong, one of the first questions that
we really want to be asking is why did
it get it wrong? And nine times out of
10 and I I'm going to come right back to
this word yet again is context. Is that
it didn't fully understand not only just
your request, but in the environment in
which it was going to be working. So,
one of my absolute um favorite features
um is
um Copilot instructions.
So, on Copilot instructions, what you're
going to notice and this is read um in
um in coding agent and it's also read on
every single um chat request
Oh, how do I
um
Yes.
I figured out a shortcut key on a Mac.
Go me.
Thank you.
Um
Hey.
what you're going to notice here is I
have Copilot-instructions.md.
This is looked at by coding agent and
it's also looked at by every single chat
request that I make inside the IDE. And
what you're going to notice in here is I
have a really nice high-level overview
of what I'm doing and how it is that I'm
doing it. So, I've given it a little bit
of introduction about the app itself and
how it is that I'm building it. I've
given it code standards. I've told it
everything that's required before
commit. I gave it some global language
guidance and then I gave it some
specifics on on what it is that I'm
building and how it is that I want it to
be built. And then if I scroll all the
way down, you'll even notice that I
highlighted that repository structure.
So, that way I'm clearly spelling out,
"This is where to go find things." So,
this is a big place to go in and look if
you want Copilot to have some additional
context, some additional information. Um
another big thing that you can do, again
speaking to things that both coding
agent and Copilot chat are are able to
use, is to stand up an MCP server. So,
this is actually one of the other
exercises in the lab um is model context
protocol. And basically what an MCP
server allows you to do, and I have a
slide
right here that shows you the uh the
diagram. I need everybody to memorize
this diagram. There's going to be a quiz
on this later.
Fantastic. Um
but basically here's what happened is
somebody goes in, they make a request to
Copilot. Copilot can then look through
the list of commands that have been
exposed out through different MCP
servers
and then from there go access external
data. Because this is always one of the
challenges whenever I'm working with
Copilot or really anything that's built
on top of an LLM is that typically it's
going to be limited to just that
training set and that's it. This allows
it to access external uh information and
even perform operations on your behalf
as well. So, if you see Copilot coding
agent doing things in a way that you
weren't quite expecting, take a look at
its context, take a look at what it has.
So, look at your Copilot instructions,
maybe put an MCP server. So, if you've
got like a really um uh large repo, a
really large code base and you want
Copilot to be able to like better search
and better reason over that, this is a
place where like standing up an MCP
server um would come into uh come into
play. Now, um I do want to highlight one
last thing um
uh because Harold is in the room and um
uh he would be very disappointed in me
if I uh didn't highlight this. Um and
this is dot instructions files um which
and I am not saying this just because
Harold is in the room. This is one of
the of of of the things that uh that
Harold works on. Um I'm not saying that
just because he is here. This is true.
This is one of my absolute favorite
little features um
where when we think about um what we're
doing in coding uh is we're doing a lot
of the same thing over and over again.
Like I'm going in and I'm creating yet
another React component or in this case
here, I'm creating yet another Flask
endpoint. But I probably want all of
those to follow a particular pattern.
And so, what I can do is I can create a
dot instructions file and I can then
manually add this into chat and this dot
instructions file can then have
information about how it is that I want
it to be created, the different rules
around it, and then even point to
prototype files that basically say,
"Hey, you see that games file over
there? Use that. That's how I want this
to be built. Hey, you see that test
file? Use that. That's how I want it to
be built."
And I can even have this happen
automatically that you'll notice that I
have apply to header info.
And so now, if it matches this pattern,
so if it's inside the server test folder
and starts with test underscore, it's
going to automatically apply that. So,
let's say again going to React
components, I can then go ahead and set
up a filter. So, anything that ends with
a JSX uh TSX um extension, I want it to
apply this. If you're a Svelte developer
like I am,
um
All right. Okay. All right. I got a
couple people. Fantastic. Beautiful. Um
then I can go ahead and set up a pattern
so that anything that ends with dot
Svelte is going to follow the
instructions here. Now, again, this part
here right now only available inside of
Copilot chat, but again, other ways that
I can start to provide context. That was
an awful lot on context. There was a
question over here. Yeah.
How often do you update this?
Yeah, this is a great question is um how
often do I do you update this? Keep in
mind that this is an artifact of your
repository and I very much want to treat
that as such. So, um I sort of give this
an analogy to, you know those little
scripts that you spend like 3 days
writing, but it's going to save you 5
minutes a day?
That's basically what these are. Is that
you're going to spend some time and you
really should create your instructions
file, create your dot instructions file.
Like really make these robust because
what you're going to wind up with then
on the back end is increased
productivity, but you're also then going
to help ensure that the code that's
being generated is generated the way
that you want it to be generated. So, as
things change, then do that. Yes, Mr.
Harold.
Yeah. And I would even add like to that
that, you know, one of the things that's
relatively unique about being in DevRel
is I do an awful lot of demos
and one of the things about doing a demo
is you need that to work.
And doing that with um a probabilistic
tool like GitHub Copilot um does become
a little bit of an adventure. That will
be the word that I will use there. Um
and instructions files have been
probably the number one thing that I
have leaned on to help ensure that I get
some level of consistency. So, I really
can't overstate the importance of
instructions file. And again, I'm not
just saying that cuz Harold's in the
room.
Yeah.
Well, when you make those. Yeah,
absolutely. Yeah.
Yep.
So, um so, the the question is is that
um hey, inside your issue, you told it
something that it probably should have
been able to find elsewhere. That it was
inside the instruction file
um and um and you still typed it out.
Like, you know, do you really need to do
that? Fantastic question. So, I'm I'm
going to answer that directly, but then
I'm also going to up-level that um uh as
well. So, to answer the question
directly, I really didn't need to. Um
but this really again kind of falls
under that category of like not being
passive-aggressive with Copilot. Like,
if there's something that I know, typing
it out isn't going to hurt anything. So,
adding that to that, if anything, it's
just going to help it because now I'm
just like further reinforcing the fact
that, "Hey, this does need to to to
actually work." Um now, I am going to
up-level real quick because I think this
also then brings up another question,
which is, "Hey, now we've got the issue
here." Um and especially like if I'm
working with um with Copilot Chat, where
now I could have like a dot instructions
file. And we've already seen that I can
have those call other files. And then
now I've got my Copilot instructions.
And so that then kind of begs the next
question, which is, "Well, is there a
hierarchy here?" And the answer is, "No,
that there isn't any form of a last
right, that it's going to consider all
of that context and then make its best
decision from there." Which also then
kind of leads to another thing, which we
should really be focused in on, like
John was highlighting with like our team
leads, is let's try to be consistent.
So, let's not start sending mixed
messages because just like if we start
sending mixed messages to our team and
they're going to get confused, the exact
same thing is going to happen with uh
with Copilot.
Yeah.
Uh I can open up holes in a firewall.
So, um if I'm using MCP locally from
inside VS Code, good to go. If um I'm
getting coding agent to do that, then um
when I add in the MCP server, I also
need to open up the firewall. All of
it's actually really well documented um
um uh to to highlight all of that, but
yes, the straight answer is yes.
Yeah, so um so when you go in and and
configure that, you can um do that at
the repo level. I believe you can do
that at the org level as well. And then
what you do is you then set variables um
and you can do that again at the repo
level or you can do that at the
organization level. So, you can
centralize all of that.
Um so,
I'm going to I I I'm going to inject my
own question into that first and then
I'm going to come back and answer that
question. So, the first question is,
"Can you review the code?" And I I I
want to make sure that I I mention this
because it's so incredibly important. Um
AI does not change
the DevOps flow. That if I think about
how I wrote code before AI, um I would
write code off my own memory, I would be
um writing code based on code that I'm
seeing elsewhere, I would write code by
copying and pasting from Stack Overflow,
making a couple of changes, and then
just crossing my fingers and hoping and
praying that it works.
Or maybe that's just me.
Or maybe I'm just the only one willing
to admit it. Um
So, in
in that situation, what do I have? I
have a DevOps flow where I'm going to
get John to come along and and review
it. I'm going to have linters that are
going to come in and check to make sure
that I'm following all my standards. I'm
going to have security scans that are
going to look for any potential
vulnerabilities. Then I'm and I have all
of these different things, all of these
these these these safeguards to help
ensure that the code that gets into my
codebase is secure and is written the
exact way that we want it to be written.
When I'm using AI, all of that still
stands. So, um I want my manual code
reviews. I want my security checks. I
want my linters. I want my unit tests. I
want all of that to go in and run. Now,
to get specific to
um the the second half of your question
there, which is, "Hey, it's just this
one file that I want you to look at." Um
when I'm working with coding agent um
or really Copilot in general, there's
always a non-zero chance that it's not
going to follow what you want it to do
exactly. So, if I say, "Hey, go in and
update this file," it it might work
specifically on that file and really in
particular when I'm working about with
with agent mode, it might work with that
one file, but it also might do a couple
of other things as well and there's not
necessarily a way to guarantee that it's
only going to do just that. If you want
it to only ever do just like that one
particular file, this is where like edit
mode comes into play. This is where ask
mode comes into play inside my IDE
because in those situations, I'm
steering rather than letting um
um
uh then then then letting Copilot steer.
I So, there's always a chance that um
when
again, Copilot is probabilistic. So,
there's always a chance it's not going
to give me the code exactly the way that
I want it to. But remember that at the
end of the day, what this has done is
this has created
Just open this up inside of a brand new
tab. This has created a brand new
branch. And so, I could go in and add in
a comment and tell Copilot, "Hey, I want
you to fix this."
But this is also a branch. So, I could
then just go in and say, "Hey, let me
create a brand new branch on that
space." Or I could go in and um
uh and then just clone that and then
just check out that branch and then go
in and manually make the changes as
well. And so like in the situation that
you're describing where, "Hey, maybe
everything looks good, but it's just
this one file that I need to modify."
Honestly, in that situation, I think
what I would do is I would just go ahead
and
um
I would just do this is
get checkout.
Yes.
And
Copilot's great at generating get
commands. It is.
Um so, uh yeah, so I could just go in
and do that. Now I can just modify
manually or like I could just work with
Copilot here then on whatever it was
that I uh that I was wanting to do.
Yeah.
Sure.
Yes.
So, um so that I I'm going to kind of
up-level all of this. So, the question
is is, "Can it go to a remote server? Um
how long does that session last? Um
etc." And the the short answer to, "Can
it access the remote server?" Yes. "Can
it act on your behalf?" Yes. "How long
is that going to last?" That depends. Um
that um when you go to set up that
connection to that remote server, you're
going to provide a credential um for
that. So, in the case of say like the
GitHub um um MCP server, then I can go
in and I can provide a token for that.
But then I can set an expiration on that
token.
Yeah. So, it's all that's really going
to depend. There isn't anything in
Copilot that's um going to
um automatically like sign you out or
anything like that.
Correct. Yeah, so I it's uh the MCP
server is not just automatically going
to be able to do something on my behalf.
I'm going to have to indicate, "Hey, I
want to do this." And then on top of
that, um and I don't think I've got it
set up um on here and it would just take
me a couple of minutes to do it. Um but
if I go in and I make a request that's
going to kick off an MCP server, I
actually have a button that says, "Hey,
do you want to do this?" Which actually
leads me right into my next point, which
is um
that my I I want to make sure that I'm
vetting my MCP servers just like I would
anything else that's going to access
external information, just like anything
else that's going to be able to act on
my behalf.
Sure.
We're getting into a lot of specifics.
Let's talk afterwards. All right, yeah.
So, for coding agent, and again, I'm I'm
just to make sure that we're clear, this
is where I'm on github.com. Right now,
we're not exposing out the model that's
being used internally um and there's a
reason for that um because we have a
very specific type of workload, a very
specific set of scenarios that need to
um to be accomplished here. And so the
model that we're choosing is the model
that's specifically like that that we've
determined is best for doing this. There
might come a time where that starts to
get exposed out and maybe that that
allows for change, but as of right now,
it's it's specifically because it works
with this. Yes, you still have your hand
raised.
Yeah.
Um yeah, I mean
Yeah, like I I I can create 100 issues
and assign all 100 of them to uh to to
to coding agent.
Yeah.
Yeah, so remember that each time that
you assign an issue to a coding agent,
it's going to create an environment
specifically for that issue.
Exactly.
Yep.
Yeah.
Um so
um
what you can do, and I actually have an
example of that right here. Yeah, so
you'll notice that right here, um I'm
actually
um
inside this dot instructions file, I'm
actually referencing out to another dot
instructions file.
Yep. And then on the apply to, you could
go in and start setting folders as well.
So, however it is that you want that to
be set up.
Yep. Yeah.
Yeah.
Sure?
Yeah, so if you're working with coding
agent, you can configure your list of
MCP servers at the organization level or
on individual repos for um
um for anything that's going to be
inside of uh VS Code, and I'm not sure
how others would um would necessarily be
um have that set up. Um you can actually
just set up inside of a repository or
inside your repository, your MCP JSON
file, um which is what I've got right
here.
And then I can just list them all here.
That now becomes part of the uh the
repository. Um the user will then still
need to set up their own credentials,
because again, it's going to act on on
that user's behalf.
Correct. Correct. Yep. Yeah.
Mr. Harold.
Oh, okay. Thank you.
What time is your talk?
Okay.
Yeah.
So, you know, I'm actually going to to
kind of up-level this. Um one of the
things about using MCP servers all up
with agent mode is that Copilot does
need to figure out which MCP server to
call um and when to call it. And
generally speaking, it's going to be
able to do that on its own, but again
and and and let this maybe be the number
one lesson that we pick up from from
today, that if I ever see Copilot not
doing something the way that I expect it
to do, what am I going to do?
There we go. I'm going to well, or even
even more generically, I you know, back
I used to be a tech trainer. Um
um so I would like literally just like
go around different companies to teach
classes. And one of the things I would
do is I would have little um um little
bits of candy um and just like toss them
out to like the little baby Reeses um
and toss us out, and I wish I had one.
Um but uh but yeah, exactly. Like update
your instructions file or again, like
improve your context. And so like one of
the things that you could do is if you
know for this specific type of scenario,
this is the MCP server I want you to
talk to, put it inside your instructions
file. And in fact, Azure, um their MCP
server, when you register it, VS Code
will actually prompt you and go, "Hey,
do you want to add that into your um
Here you go. There you go. There you go.
Um but um
but if you install the Azure MCP server,
it will actually say, "Hey, you should
add this to your instructions file."
Okay. That was a lot of questions.